é a minha apresentação então receber o
título de saifi prevendo futuras senha
mas na verdade a ficção científica já
tem praticamente o dobro de existência
de é de tempo de existência e isso
porque a primeira obra de ficção
científica considerada a primeira obra é
o romance frankenstein de mary shelley
que foi publicado em 1818 então ano que
vem tanto romance enquanto gênero da
ficção científica comemoram 200 anos e
desde aquela época já existia essa
comparação entre as inovações
tecnológicas e as pesquisas científicas
com a narrativa da ficção científica ea
própria narrativa do frank estágio era
baseada em uma coisa ainda mais antiga
que essa tentativa de criar vida através
de uma ferramenta no caso na alquimia os
alquimistas tentavam criar vida a partir
do conceito do munco né
e hoje em dia a gente tenta criar vida
sintéticas a partir da inteligência
artificial da robótica então enquanto lá
na o que me era como se fosse quase uma
magia hoje a gente tem esse lado mais
tecnológico do desenvolvimento de
inteligência artificial por exemplo
e aí tem essas três leis de clark corte
seco aqui um autor de ficção científica
e futurólogo que dizia que às vezes é
uma tecnologia é tão avançada que ela
até parece ser uma magia parece magia e
aí eu trouxe pra gente fazer essa
relação entre magia e tecnologias
inspiração na ficção para tecnologia e
inovação tecnológica um steel desses
dessa série que foi lançada no ano
passado pelo national geographic channel
chama mars é uma série que mistura tanto
um lado especulativo da ficção pensando
como seria uma primeira missão
colonizador em marte e também é unido
depoimentos de especialistas
pesquisadores cientistas e empresários
que estão trabalhando para que isso se
torne uma realidade então você tem
depoimentos por exemplo do vilão mas que
têm iniciativa spacex decolaria de
colonização em marte
ao mesmo tempo que tem na área da ficção
em que se especula como seria essa
missão é colonizadora como seriam os
problemas que as pessoas enfrentariam lá
e quais seriam as aventuras que eles
teriam ea idéia é justamente como a
ficção faz com que a gente possa
imaginar esses cenários é o que o ator
se claro que eu falei pra vocês um autor
de ficção científica principalmente
conhecido por ter feito por ter
publicado o romance 2001 uma odisséia no
espaço mais tarde adaptado pelo cinema
por stanley kubrick e ele fala que a
ficção às vezes é muito
o mais importante do que a não ficção
porque ela justamente nos ajuda a criar
universos abrir a nossa mente pensar
sinais do futuro e isso é muito
importante num momento de grandes
mudanças e isso ele falou em 2004 pouco
santos há poucos anos antes de ele
morrer em 2008 com 90 anos
então imagina agora em 2017 com mais
coisas ainda acontecendo mesmo tempo e
hortas e claro que ele não só tinha sua
participação na ficção científica como
ele também tinha uma formação acadêmica
como físico e matemático e ele
participava ativamente da comunidade
científica por exemplo indicando papers
como em 1945 e publicou um paper sobre a
técnica tecnologia é tão básica pra
gente hoje os atalhos de estacionários
ele foi tão importante no
desenvolvimento dessa tecnologia que
hoje é a órbita do satélite e
institucionais que são a base da nossa
comunicação de celular telefone internet
recebeu o nome de órbita clark e aí se
perguntar lhe deu mas onde é que você
começou a fazer essa comparação de
ficção científica e inovação tecnológica
né isso começou em 2009 quando eu fiz a
minha primeira pesquisa acadêmica foi
iniciação científica sobre uma animação
japonesa chamadas e experientes lei
basicamente essa ficção trata de
questões filosóficas desde identidade
memória religião e basicamente um pano
de fundo dela é falar sobre a uma rede
no caso da internet que é chamada a
wired e lá eles propõem que as pessoas
conseguem se conectar essa rede sem os
dispositivos esse 98 quando o iphone
estava sendo desenvolvido e só estava
começando a se popularizar
principalmente no japão então eles
fizeram esse salto especulativo de
pensar como a gente se conectarem à
internet saltando do desktop para o
celular o iphone está sendo desenvolvido
até porque por exemplo um implante
neural que poderia fazer com que a gente
se conectar se à internet sem uso de
dispositivos por exemplo de tela e esse
é um projeto justamente que o vilão mas
que também está investindo agora esse
ano na empresa que lançou recentemente
que a neura link mas guardem essa
informação que eu já vou falar sobre
isso
a idéia é que basicamente a ficção
científica pode ser dividida em 2 duas
grandes categorias a rádio saifi ea soft
saifi a rádio foi a mais antiga é
baseada por exemplo nas obras dos
autores como artes e claques a crise
moby robert ray lá em que tinha um
background mais científico por exemplo
sendo físico matemático na biologia e
tal
eles usavam os conhecimentos científicos
justamente para fundamentar a tecnologia
que eles usavam para discutir questões
filosóficas sociológicas e afins
mas nos anos 60 autores como o filipe
que de começar a quebrar um pouco com
essa necessidade de fundamentação
teoricamente a tecnologia que era usado
de background para a narrativa dele
então ele trazia mais questionamentos
com foco em por exemplo filosofia
sociologia da religião psicologia e tal
ele ficou conhecido principalmente por
causa do romance dele do androids dream
of electric sheep que foram foi adaptado
para o cinema em 1984 como blade runner
pelo inglês scott e lá no em 84 já
começaram a discutir por exemplo
questões como o android super realistas
né
e hoje a gente pode dizer que já existem
andróides assim na verdade desde 2003
quando foi criada a primeira ginóide que
seria a forma feminina de um andróide
super realista por pesquisadores de uma
universidade sul coreana a every one
ela foi criada como por exemplo é uma
combinação da da aparência das
principais cantoras e atrizes coreanas
na época em e ela tinha como função a
possibilidade de ser instalada por
exemplo em lojas e museus para oferecer
informações ou contar histórias para as
crianças
e aí teve outro desenvolvimento tanto no
japão quanto na coreia e tal mas eu
trouxe esse exemplo por último do ano
passado que causou um burburinho porque
esse esse design chinesa abandonou a
carreira dele para se dedicar totalmente
na criação dessas noite sozinho em casa
e aí a polêmica que surgiu é porque ela
é exatamente a cara da scarlett
johansson apesar de ele não assumir o
engraçado é que enquanto anos faz negra
cara do futuro nos anos 90 talvez hoje a
scarlett johansson ou seja a cara do
futuro desde lucy até gol sem deixar a
adaptação americana que que foi feita
e aí o filipe cage que também ele teve
essa importância já nos anos 70 de
começar a tratar de assuntos como o
universo simulados né
uma coisa que ficou bem popular no final
dos anos 90 quando matrix foi lançado
aquela ideais ele está vivendo no matrix
tal será que determina uma simulação de
computador e já nos anos 70 o filho
porque ele falava disso
o engraçado é interessante a história do
filho que jack porque quando ele foi
fazer extração do sisu dele recebeu uma
anestesia com um componente químico que
fez com que ela assinasse tivesse visões
e a partir disso ele mudou o ponto de
vista da vida dele ea própria produção
de ficção dele também mudou de uma
virada e ele fazia palestras falando a
gente pode ser que esteja vivendo no
mundo simulado esse 99 rebuscado com o
matrix em 2003 quatro anos depois um
filósofo e futurista chamado nick
bostrom publicou um artigo acadêmico
falando justamente sobre a hipótese de
que estaríamos vivendo ano no universo
simulado existem pessoas que realmente
acreditam nessa hipótese como o próprio
milan mas que abertamente falou que ele
acredita que a gente pode estar vivendo
no mundo simulado o próprio matrix na
verdade é como se fosse uma adaptação
cinematográfica muito inspirado em uma
obra que foi seminal nos anos 80 para a
criação de um novo subgênero da ficção
científica que é o cyber punk lado
estados unidos alguns autores escritores
começaram com essa vertente sendo alguns
dos principais expoentes o bruce
sterling e william gibson que escreveu o
principal referência do gênero que é o
neuromancer é publicar em 84 e lá o
número mancini já começou a tratar de
coisas como cultura hacker implantes
neurais ou implantes mesmo membros
biônicos e tal e aí a isso é uma coisa
que que é dito discutido no matrix mesmo
pois se vocês lembrarem aquela cena do
new que ele consegue fazer o download de
artes marciais e consegue lutar na hora
já no romance também tinha essa ideia e
isso que o irmão mas que está propondo
esse ano com a neurolinguística
justamente para como ele vê que a unasul
está cada vez mais popular dupla
inteligências artificiais à maneira do
ser humano continuar a relevante é
justamente fazer essa fusão entre homem
e máquina
mas antes da gente dar esse salto
cognitivo a partir dessa fusão ainda se
o simbolismo é extremamente em alta e
isso você pode ver por exemplo no ano
passado aí do monte é uma desenvolvedora
de videogames lançou o segundo título da
série deus ex mais recente é um
videogame mais antigo né
e aí lá tem esse personagem principal
que é o adam jensen que ele tem um braço
protético e os fãs começaram a mandar
mensagens próprio e do monte vai
perguntando nós como eu posso pra ter um
braço igual como eu faço para comprar
pois bem eles não a gente vai
desenvolvedora de jogos
eles tiveram um estalo e resolveram
fazer uma parceria com uma startup
chamada open bar e olha que divide que
justamente desenvolve membros
prostéticos então hoje quem quiser o
código aberto pode imprimir em casa o
city uma impressora 3d o braço
igualzinho do adam jensen e eles viram
justamente nisso uma possibilidade não
só de fazer essa parceria como também
divulgar a questão do simbolismo tanto a
promovendo eventos como esse problema no
ano passado em agosto em nova york o rio
- vai design para discutir questões
éticas e tecnológicas o simbolismo
divulgando projetos e pessoas que têm
membros prostéticos como é o caso da mp
pede que é uma atleta e dançarina que no
ano passado fez aquela performance com
robô na abertura das paraolimpíadas no
rio
ou então ainda outros artistas como a
vitória modesta que tem uma uma perna
biônica também ela usa isso como toda
acessório de moda quando uma manifesto
artístico e aqui no brasil a gente tem
uma reta chamada estalo que também
passou a assumir a perna protética dela
como um símbolo de resistência das
minorias que ela representa
tá bom mas se vocês querem realmente dá
um salto enorme nessa questão do
simbolismo
a gente tem é tanto quem viu adaptação
americana agora eu gosto de shell o
filme de 95 do mamoru oshii vocês sabem
que a protagonista ela tem o corpo
inteiro bié biônico e só o cérebro
biológico dela foi transportado para
esse corpo e esse é justamente a
proposta dessa iniciativa 2045 liderada
por um empresário russo chamado dimitri
e descobre que ele propõe quatro etapas
de transição para que a gente consiga
alcançar a imortalidade a partir desse
organismo no caso até 2020 e prevê que
ele tem vai ter um corpo robótico com o
qual a gente vai conseguir se conectar
parte de uma de uma interface cérebro
computador
então como se fosse um avatar mas taxa
de poder literalmente transplantar o
nosso cérebro a esse princípio robótico
até que em 2045 a gente perca essa
materialidade e seres de luz eles de
holograma mesmo que é uma proposta
também aparece nos quadrinhos e menor de
final dos anos 90 chamaram
transmetropolitan dando orgulho neles e
aí tem essa vertente se disse borghi
para tentar alcançar a imortalidade e
combater o envelhecimento mas ainda tem
a vertente da biologia com um
gerontologista aubrey
gay por exemplo ou ainda calico leves
como iniciativa do google que pesquisa
justamente dessa vertente biológica como
acabar com o envelhecimento como vence a
morte e afins
tá bom todos esses assuntos já estão
sendo salvas da ficção científica fazia
muito tempo e talvez a gente nem
soubesse que já está acontecendo no
âmbito da pesquisa científica e
tecnológica né e aí a grande a grande
sacada disse como a ficção científica
pode-se pano de fundo de inspiração da
inovação tecnológica
se você pegar por exemplo a óculos quem
começa a trabalhar já recebe uma uma
cópia do livro um grande player banco
que foi a base de inspiração do palm
leque que o fundador do óculos pra criar
a tecnologia de realidade virtual que
eles têm hoje com headset óculos e ele
fala justamente isso todos nós aqui
criamos essa tecnologia temos um
background de ficção científica a gente
não tem a tecnologia que agora mas daqui
10 20 anos a gente quer alcançar o que a
gente viu na ficção científica
e aí é basicamente isso a idéia de que a
ficção científica tem servido justamente
de inspiração pra gente visionar esses
cenários como artes e clark diz pra que
a gente possa visualizar esse universo
expandir a nossa mente e pensar no que a
gente pode transformar esse futuro
basta a gente escolher qual é o futuro
que a gente quer é isso obrigada
[Aplausos]